I've been actually very removed from
like gossip because we're not forced to
be informed the only thing that's
keeping me informed is the toasters
Jackie and Gloria Audrey are sisters
that you may not have heard of but your
kids for sure have and for good reason
that's true our new series girl boss
looks at the content creators that are
young and influential and today our
focus is on Jackie and Claudia who's
already massive social media empire is
getting even bigger I think it's always
been our dream to me morning show hosts
but when you look at the current daytime
setup as a 24 and 26 year old woman I
don't necessarily feel represented nor
do I see a show that I'm like dying to
watch good morning Millennials we
created the morning show we wish to see
in the world
sisters Jackie and Claudia Autry taught
pop culture on the morning toast
streaming live every weekday on YouTube
for almost a year now but their careers
began no shocker at social media
influencers I started to realize while I
was in college that like this is a real
profession is you know social media
marketing today Jackie's jackieo
problems has 200,000 Instagram followers
Claudia's path was a bit more unorthodox
it began thanks to a bad experience with
a fashion internship in college had all
these funny experiences that were so
treacherous that I started a blog called
girl with a job I started it on tumblr
it was really like for fun it wasn't to
become anything it was like a diary
almost it basically just like said mean
things about people that I worked with
Claudia eventually got fired and turned
her content into girl with no job her
stream of relatable memes some she
writes herself some she doesn't has 3
million followers and she's got a high
engagement rate which big brands love I
really fell into like meme entertainment
humor content on Instagram and OHS on
Instagram really early and it just
became its own brand on Instagram and
now we're figuring out different ways to
do things with it like just as for the
toast
the sisters cover topics like the
Kardashians housewives and bachelor when
we joined them former bachelor Nick
Viall was a guest for the guests we use
our Instagram that's our Booker it's
very very fancy Booker she's very
expensive
and I'm more than I even realized yes
between the two of us we operate a whole
business justice to people's but we take
on really different roles so I'm
definitely like standards and HR and
setting the rules but Claudia is really
like the comedic genius and their empire
is expanding there's a morning toast
podcast and Claudia's comedy towards a
dirty jeans tour a feeling of failure
like weeks me up every morning and when
I don't want to get up and I'm tired I'm
like you're gonna fail if you don't I
mean I'm so afraid to fail especially me
to put up our own money to start the
show and get a studio production and
like the the financial investment but
also the emotional investment is what
keeps me up at night thank God it paid
off
you